[Music]
alright time for the matinee show
matinee number 51 yeah new movies yeah
we saw two in the theater this week and
we saw one that was exclusive to shudder
which I think also got a limited
theatrical release but it didn't play
here but I've seen it on shudder yeah
you want to do that one first yeah we're
gonna talk about that one first cuz we
saw that one the earliest this is the
horror film Tigers are not afraid yeah
now I had heard a lot about there was a
lot of buzz about this because I guess
it kind of made the rounds of a lot of
film festivals and stuff and it got
really good reviews and it got like some
kind of like famous horror authors like
coming out you know advocating for it
and as I said it did get a limited
theatrical release but it didn't play in
any theaters here that I know but I had
been hearing about it for a long time
and just probably about five days ago
from when we're recording this shudder
added it and it's a shudder exclusive
and I think it's also streaming on
shutter in Canada and I think in the UK
as well so it's on there if you want to
see it now this movie is really in this
is a really really good movie I liked
this a lot it's kind of like it's
reminding me very much of the guillermo
del toro movie The Devil's Backbone
it's very much in that kind of vein it's
like basically magical realism it's not
quite as fantastical as Gamera Deltora
stuff tends to be like easily not as you
know fantastical let's say like Pan's
Labyrinth or something but it's
definitely a kind of thing where
everything is kind of seen through the
eyes of a child you know there's like a
horrible you know war-torn situation you
know and all these kids that have to put
up with this stuff and like then there's
like a fantasy element that you're not
sure is like really real or if it's like
you know the way that the kids are
dealing with you know the horrors around
them cats tearing [ __ ] up again a type
of boogie she's such a bad yeah she's
been getting on my nerves all day yeah
she really wants daddy to pay attention
but yeah so this was actually written
and directed by isso Lopez who I guess I
haven't seen any of other movies but
apparently she's like a really famous
like writer and director she does like a
lot of movies and
TV in Mexico and this is actually set
around I don't think they ever say what
town it was do they I thought was DJ it
might be but it's like I don't remember
saying in the town or not but it's in
Mexico and it's kind of in the grips of
you know these kind of drug cartels or
drug gangs that are like fighting with
each other and they don't ever get
caught for anything because they have
ties to like this politician that's
either running for office or is already
in office so basically you know that
there's all this stuff about you know
people's parents being taken you know
for trafficking purposes or whatever and
similar to Rambo actually yeah well ya
know what I'm sayin yeah yeah talk about
which we'll get to in a little bit but
so you know so there's this whole thing
it's like all these like orphans so the
main character in this is a little girl
named Estrella and she's ten years old
and at the very beginning of the movie
there's kind of like she's in school and
they're talking about fairytales because
like I said this is has a very fairytale
feel to it and there's like a shooting
like a gang shooting like outside the
school so the kids are all like under
the desks and freaking out and
everything and her teacher gives her
three pieces of chalk and she says that
these were magical wishes now as soon as
like Estrella gets out of school and she
sees the dead guy like right outside the
school like he's all covered up and
there's blood everywhere and then like
this stream of blood starts to let go by
itself and like it leads all the way
back to her house and when she gets back
to her house she discovered discovers
that her mother is gone like so her
mother has been taken by one of the drug
gangs
so Estrella is now an orphan and so she
goes to live with this other group of
boys that are orphans and they live on
like these little rooftops and stuff and
kind of steal to get by and all this
other stuff and like I said there's kind
of like really cool like fantasy
elements to it the first part of it is
almost kind of like I've seen it
compared to city of God so it is kind of
similar to that I've seen it compared to
Sin Nombre if you've seen that but it so
there's like all these little things
where the the first part of it is kind
of filmed almost like a war documentary
like it's
like there's a lot of handheld camera
and stuff but then there's these little
elements like I said like this
blood-trail Astraeus starts thinking
because the first wish that she makes
with her chalk is that she does that her
mother would come back and it does seem
like her mother comes back but like sort
of as a ghost or like a revenant or
something that she kind of sees in the
shadows and then there's like all this
Tiger imagery because the Tigers
represent you know the the kids I guess
the the way they handle their fear like
fighting back against the drug lords and
things like that they like it's a symbol
of bravery and and and [ __ ] like that so
there's a lot of Tiger imagery like
there's little tiger
you know graffiti on the wall that like
it becomes animated one of the orphan
kids who's like a four year old I think
his name is marito and he has like a
little stuffed tiger that that he
carries around that like comes to life
later on in the film but the interesting
thing about it is that you're not sure
like I said if Estrella
because Estrella is the only one seeing
this stuff like nobody else says hey the
Tigers walking around or nobody anything
like that yeah so it might just be it
could be that it's real because there is
like some there are some like the wishes
that she makes do come true although not
in the way that she affects them say oh
hi interpreted is this as psychic
visions yeah it could have been it could
be it could be read either way yeah it's
pretty cool you know the man it's kind
of like she said it's like a Garrett
Guillermo del Toro film very much like
The Devil's bachelor - that Street gets
get tied in with the drug cartels the
kid steals a gun and the first act of
the movie yeah from like oh yeah and it
is phone - that's why they start coming
after the kids because yes there is kind
of like a kind of like action and
adventure scenes in the movie yes so it
was a good mix so it's entertaining you
know it's cut across genre in a way
almost kind of like crime thriller
paranormal adventure slightly horror
movie
yeah it's everything kind of with with
like some paranormal stuff happening in
it so I think it was a pretty good movie
I think it I think you know just even
the average person you know who's not
really big into these genres would be
entertained by it yeah because in a lot
of ways he's really good the kids in
this are
amazing and um oh Sh
swell so yeah it's yeah it's a Mexican
director yeah you wouldn't really want
to watch this dubbed into English I
don't want to watch it nothing dubbed is
any good no the dumping isn't ever never
as good as the original act uh you know
original language yeah you know the subs
are easy to follow it's not a
complicated story not really and it's
like like you said it's it's almost kind
of like and I was watching a couple of
the reviews of it and one guy said he
wasn't sure he'd even call it a horror
movie it's definitely a horror movie but
it's got like aspects of dark fantasy to
it it's got like it's weird to say that
it's like oh it's really grounded in
reality but then it has like dark
fantasy on top of it like I said it's
not quite as out there it's there's not
like monsters or anything like that like
in some of Deltora know they're ghosts
but there's ghosts there's like just
like weird imitations yeah like I said
the trail of blood I was thought it was
some kind of psychic vision to help her
figure fine things yeah yeah like it was
leading her like a wagon or somewhere
yeah you know don't want to spoil too
much of the movie but yeah this is this
is definitely a pretty really good movie
um you know and and I can see why it's
been getting like so much so many
accolades because I think it won awards
it pretty much every festival of play is
quality but yeah definitely definitely
good movie and like I said del Toro came
out like advocating for it Stephen King
has come out advocating Neil Gaiman so
like this has got like a lot of big
names like backing up on and like you
know recommending yeah they're not wrong
yeah and I would definitely recommend it
just keep in mind it's not you know it's
it's almost like a realistic type of
movie it's almost like a horror take on
like I said City of God or if you really
like The Devil's Backbone you should
really really dig this because it's very
very similar so yeah it's on shudder
right now so you should probably go and
check it out
now the next movie we saw this week
actually popped up in the theaters with
like no warning no nothing ya know
nobody really knows about this movie
I've in town everybody about it they're
like what yeah it's really weird it's
like I didn't even see and we go to the
movies all the time you guys look for
the show I didn't even see new trailers
for this it's just like popped up on my
AMC app and I'm like call freaks yeah
I'm like what is that all about freaks
was a real good one I liked it I enjoyed
every bit of this movie I did too this
was like surprisingly good or something
that just kind of came out of nowhere I
went into it not knowing anything enough
for the first like 15 missile you know
they're afraid to go outside this guy's
got his daughter Nate and he's towner
don't go outside he's make it a remember
a bunch of stuff and there's some weird
effects going on every now and then yeah
it's not really explained I'm almost
don't want to spoil it yeah I'm gonna
try it on say oh yeah if you liked
firestarter that old Stephen King movie
yeah this reminded me a lot a lot like
that it's also has elements of the story
kind of like x-men yeah this is not a
superhero movie but it kind of is it's
the premise that super superhero movies
are kind of founded on it's psychics
basically yeah people with weird psychic
abilities and paranormal powers and it's
somehow genetic which is kind of like
something out of x-men yeah it's similar
to that like it's not this is a very um
it's very low-budget but this is one
where no but this is one where could
because the writing is so good in the
story no compelling that you don't
really notice that it's been like a few
locations and stuff yeah it doesn't
matter
yeah and that just yeah you don't need a
[ __ ] ton of money and like you know tons
of CGI and shows we've got to make
something good and worth watching yeah
and I guess I could probably give this
away these these psychics are a threat
because they're [ __ ] powerful well in
the same way that the girl in
firestarter yeah so there's a government
agency's hunting them down and I guess
killing kill
yeah yeah the guy special concentration
can't form it's like something out of
Fallout big vault in the center of a
mountain and it's about some people who
are some of these psychics are being
hunted down now kind of like the similar
premise that a firestarter what was his
name Rain Bird reindeer who worked for
the dam I think it was cold blood unit
something or other I can't see knit and
it was like it was a special government
unit who that hunted down sidekicks
drugged him up and studied them and
tried to figure them out you know it's
the premise like that but it's pretty
badass I don't want to give it away
about who of what these powers are yeah
because I should probably put I should
better not to know what the powers are
that's what I mean I really liked and I
think like I'll put I'll put in the
title like that there spoilers that
seemed very difficult not to spoil it is
very difficult to talk about it with
it's one of those movies where like you
really can't it's almost better if you
go into this not knowing anything yeah
that's what I was just gonna say I'm
really glad it's literally all I knew
about I didn't watch the trailer or
nothing I just saw the thing I saw the
poster and then I saw like the
two-sentence thing where it said it
called it like a sci-fi thriller about a
father and daughter you know when the
father won't let the daughter leave the
house I was all I know yeah um you know
what I mean so I'm really glad that I
didn't know because the first part of
this movie where you go in and it's just
this dad and his daughter and he's like
taping up the mail slot you think he's
crazy
you just think he's a nut because it
looks like he's like stockpiling all
this [ __ ] he's making her like repeat
all this information like about her name
which isn't her name he doesn't let her
go outside he doesn't let her go outside
she's like seven and yeah and he's like
saying all this stuff what we can't go
outside you know they'll kill us and
stuff and then but she's like looking
out the window and everything looks
pretty [ __ ] normal out there so
you're like what the hell is going on is
the dad just and not or or what but then
there's like little clues that one of
the coolest things about this movie is
that yeah a lot of the stuff is you know
explained as it goes along but a lot of
[ __ ] you gotta like look at the
backgrounds of stuff like that they'll
be like a news report on TV that's muted
you have to like read the little thing
at the moon
and a disability but it's giving you all
the hints as to what is going on yeah
yeah so I really like that they did that
because you they didn't need a big
budget to like show all of the stuff
they were talking about they would just
have it like on a news report like in a
TV in the background or stuff like that
and you kind so it kind of becomes like
things are revealed very slowly and I
like the way that they kind of played
with your expectations too because at
one point like the little girl I mean
she's seven years old who is played by
Lexi Kolker I think she's been in a
couple like small roles before this but
she pretty much carries this whole movie
for being like a little kid she was she
was really seven when this was filmed
and that's how old she is in the movie
it acting is really good across the
board the the Imagineering and the
world-building is good across the board
yeah they could totally expand this
concept oh yeah you can make a whole
series based on this yeah you know oh
yeah you definitely catch a cool [ __ ]
you could do with this yeah you could do
an MCU at this that's what I was
thinking like when I was watching it
like especially when I like when I saw
the end I was like yeah they could like
totally continue this way kind of kind
of it kind of felt kind of like bright
burn - I was thinking that as well it is
kind of similar to that in the way that
it's sort of like I don't want to call
it necessarily a superhero movie but it
did kind of remind me of that sort of
more realistic grounded you know people
with superpowers type yeah the one with
mr. glass and you know that yeah yeah my
jamaran whatever yeah a guy's name is
Colin Campbell everything goes yeah I
guess it's Shyamalan sh'mon
again but um yeah and so I was gonna say
so when she's like looking out the
window one day she sees this like yeah
this creepily hand paid an ice-cream
truck
yeah with a creepy Bruce Dern in there
yeah Brewster's I don't spoil it playing
don't spoil it playing mr. snow cone
yeah don't spoil you can't spoil this
but like I said you you think things are
gonna go one way it doesn't really good
not you expected I think I think we
ought to walk away from this one we'll
just let me and the girl like think
she's seeing ghosts in her closet and
all this other kind of there's all kind
of crazy [ __ ] going in this movie yeah
and like I said it takes a long time to
like review but I liked that I liked
this slow reveal it's like really
suspenseful because like the first part
of it you're seeing they're going what
the [ __ ] is going on it's like yeah is
there really cuz everything looks as
normal outside is like is he just crazy
and he won't let her go outside and he's
a crazy person or you know he's got
really something going on yeah we kind
of spoiled that aspect of it though well
I'll put that up I said I was gonna be
in the title so it's like if you want to
see it like don't watch the middle part
like like do that but seriously there's
a lot of movies this kind of reminds me
of like I said firestarter
x-men there's one called push which I
haven't seen but I've seen a lot of
people compare it to that bright burn
kind of a little bit of a 10 Cloverfield
Lane kind of thing as well some people
compared it to room so if you like that
kind of thing and like I said something
that can be done with like a low-budget
oh you know what else what remember
heroes that the television movie yeah
yeah yeah there's some of that but it's
a lot darker
yeah a lot more closer Bry / and you
know what's weird it's like the dad
that's the guy that plays the dad played
he's played by Emile Hirsch
and the whole movie I'm sitting there
going where the [ __ ] have I seen that
guy before
oh my god he's been in tons of [ __ ] tons
of [ __ ] he was actually in once upon a
time in Hollywood he played JC Bruno
which is on Netflix I think and you
should definitely go check that one out
too because that's an awesome movie and
he was also an into the wild so I think
I remembered him from that it's a good
flick but yeah this is a really good
play and it's just crazy how it just
kind of came out of nowhere and like I
say for any advertisement no I guess not
I didn't even see a trailer apparently
some people did but I never saw one and
like I said I'm glad that I went into it
not knowing anything about it so like I
said I put a spoiler in the title so if
you watched it says your fault oh yeah
but it's better if you go into it not
really knowing what's going on right I
mean so but yeah it's a really good
movie it's play if it's playing you're
in a theater new you should definitely
go check it out because it's really
really good
and the third movie we saw this week
starts theater Tom's been waiting for
this for a really long time did not
disappoint
Rambo Ram blast blood last blood also
known as rainbow five yeah it's awesome
it was awesome okay
the critics now they're [ __ ] trying to
tear this movie apart they're saying
it's sexist and misogynistic and it's
[ __ ] racist and [ __ ] even though the
premise is very similar to the other
ones about the Tigers Tigers yeah Tigers
are afraid yes Tigers aren't afraid you
know Mexican drug cartels and stuff yeah
and trafficking human trafficking it was
a badass flick I probably put it the the
best Rambo movie of course gonna be
first blood that first one yeah alright
this is it I'm gonna put them in order
of what I what I think is the best
alright first blood you know uh-huh
um Rambo the fight continues which is
the one before this one I like yeah I
like that it was like super super gory
yeah this one and then two and three
yeah I like them all but I don't
remember two and three it was so long
ago that I at two and three were just
movies at the time you know they weren't
bad but they just they were a big big
budget Hollywood action movies at the
time and they had a lot of the the
idiosyncrasies of those movies at the
time although you know they weren't as
cheesy as some of the other ones but you
know they were very okay they're good
yeah but um no I like this movie it's a
simple tale of revenge yeah it's not
trying to do anything real complicated
the acting and it was good story was
tight and it was just you know Rambo
he's lit he goes back home which it
where was it Arizona goes back home to
Arizona I've to his little farmers it's
somewhere near the Mexican border
he's basically kind of raised this kind
of like you know I guess it says like an
adopted daughter yeah who's this
Mexican American girl yeah Gabe
Gabrielle her name is Rick your yeah
Bree and I guess it's her grandmother I
think is also yeah they're all right
who's yeah cuz her mom's dead
Rambo's friend and ranma's got this farm
it's got tunnels underneath it and
everything he's raising horses and the
girl Gabriella she wants to find her
father who's back in Mexico the grandmas
like now I don't go down there you know
so she goes to TJ Tijuana and one thing
I'm not going to spoil at all one thing
leads to another a cartel of the narco
terrorists who also have like a human
trafficking operation have captured her
and they put her in a damn dungeon you
know and then they sent her to a brothel
Rambo of course finds out about this and
he goes to Tijuana to find her and he
gets [ __ ] up and then in the end well
in the end you know you can tell just
from the damn trailers that they end up
back at his house for a big shootout it
was just a simple movie and I liked it I
thought it was good yeah it's like it's
surprisingly this is a very short movie
they never really liked it was only like
85 minutes or something like that um
surprisingly it had a lot more character
detail yeah an hour of movie and acting
is that I was expecting yeah um it
didn't have like it had a lot of action
sequences and a lot of violence but not
as much as I thought as I thought it was
gonna have and like not as much as the
last Rambo movie which to me I mean just
yeah that was that that one just seemed
like wall-to-wall exploding heads yeah
maybe it was it but like I said that's
why I liked it super gory but this one
actually had you know the action
set-pieces were like you know well paced
like there was it was but there was like
law large like gaps in between them cuz
a lot of it was you know
Rambo's character kind of like going to
find his adopted daughter and then like
getting messed up by the drug and then
like other like he was trying to get in
help from a journalist and you know then
so it was only really big three big
action set pieces yeah yeah I have a
feeling that that there Moore was shot
but it was cut out of the movie so it
could get an r-rating yeah so they might
add it back in for thinking they're
really there's gonna be usually because
even in the Expendables series yeah you
can
get the Unrated versions of them on the
blu-ray there they're actually bigger
and better yes I think this is more of
an advertisement for the damn blu-ray
probably alright because I'm definitely
gonna buy this at blu-ray but most Rambo
fans are gonna buy the blu-ray yeah and
the blu-rays probably have a lot more on
it a lot more extra [ __ ] there is like
you know this is a satisfying movie I
was very satisfied there's a lot of gore
in it there's like you know you people
get exploded people get beheaded yeah
was that man he cuts a dude's heart out
he goes aztec on him dude there's a
there's a bunch of a lot of mexican
themes in it half the movies in spanish
with subtitles which i thought that was
a nice touch again i think the movies
gonna sell very well in Central and
South America probably yeah even though
I read that it was actually not shot in
Mexico I think of a shot in Bulgaria
Tenerife in the Canary Islands alright
yeah okay
so anyway I'm not weird yeah and I
didn't realize it looks like Mexico but
it looks like the way you think Mexico
would look like at least yeah I think it
oh [ __ ]
Rose no se but um I think the blu-ray is
gonna have more stuff on it I can figure
that it probably will yeah I liked it
but yeah the way satisfied for the movie
was satisfied with the movie um no I
thought that was good I liked it too
because it's kind of like you know he
obviously he's much older now he's in
his 70s and this is kind of like almost
like his kind of last hurrah yeah you
know what I mean like he thought he'd
finally like come to some kind of peace
in his life and then somebody can came
along and [ __ ] it up and yeah he had
to like you know get back into that mode
again yeah now I have read that because
I guess when he went to the Cannes Film
Festival to sell this one thing I heard
about this was this was not actually the
original script for the for this movie
the movie was supposed to be it was
supposed to be called Rambo 5 the savage
hunt and it was supposed to be Rambo and
a whole bunch of like Special Forces
guys fighting a genetically-engineered
Superman that was what the original
script was yeah but then you know there
was all this other rewrites and stuff
like this Sylvester Stallone did
right this he didn't direct it I think
that was a what's-his-name Adrian grunt
grunt or Grendel whatever his name is he
was the one that directed it so yeah so
apparently when when sly was it can like
talking about the movie and like you
know trying to sell it to distributors
and stuff he said that if they make
another Rambo movie cuz I don't think he
doesn't want to play the character
anymore because he's like you know he's
much older now he said if they make
another one then he's thinking about
maybe doing a prequel with like with a
young actor like before Rambo like goes
off to Vietnam yeah which I think that
actually might be a kind of interesting
yeah that might be kind of an interest I
love narration he I'd love to see an
Expendables for he got to do it
Expendables another Expendables I don't
want him to stop the whole action
military action shot yeah but I was
gonna say he had it's implied that um
Rambo
maybe mexican-american or at least part
mexican-american in it doesn't it did
they imply that well he had a daughter
who was mexican-american he spoke
Spanish and he came from right there
along that Mexican border hmm and
remember when I thought the cartel
checked his his his ID would they call
him when he wanna throw Rambo yeah I
thought there was just making fun of I
thought I thought maybe they're trying
to imply that maybe he was part Mexican
and maybe a Turkish Rambo could passes
part Mexican
he probably could yeah yeah I mean like
I said obviously Silver's denying he's a
very good but yeah but an Italian guy
could claim him so yeah well you know my
dad my mama's Mexican you know that
might work I don't know didn't okay now
at the lock hair you know at the last
end of the last Rambo movie the the
super gory when removed or whatever it
was
now wasn't that the same farm didn't he
go home at the end and the like he goes
to the farm and then there's the mail
box that says Rambo on it yeah and it
was the farm yeah okay so I was
remembering that right yeah because when
I saw the farm again I'm like I thought
what's really familiar but I didn't
remember if that happens I get they
explained it like how he got to that
almost led to believe that he grew up
there on that farm yeah and it was right
there on the Mexican border yeah and I
guess the woman that was living there
the grandmother of the of Gabriela was
she like a friend or a or the
housekeeper no she was somehow like a
friend of the family and any I guess and
or was it this girlfriend no wasn't his
girlfriend no they were she was actually
younger than semester school yeah by
quite a large market you know I don't
know I'd have to see it again at first
like I wasn't real clear like at first I
thought that she was
Gabriella's mom I think it's grand but
it was yeah it was her grandmother
because then they Slater said that there
that the mom was dead
yeah and that the dad had abandoned them
and went back to Mexico and that's what
caused all the trouble like Gabriel we
wanted to go find her biological father
but they lived with him
yeah and in the heat that farm was
pretty big yeah had a bunch of stuff on
it he had the whole thing undermined
with a bunch of tunnels yeah yeah he was
down there like making Spears like you
know like smelting get his own Forge
yeah Paul back to the other movie yeah
he was doing that so he had all kind of
like fun shut down there yeah I'd like
to see it again though it was it was I
think it was a worthy entry I you know I
think the movie will do pretty well yeah
and I know they'll do well streaming in
blu-ray people buy the [ __ ] out of that
and I think what like the the way you
ranked to them I think I would agree
with that yeah like I said I think I
liked Rambo for better just because it
was like gory ER and like yeah it was
non-stop - action - and this one was
much more like subdued yeah it had a lot
of like gore in it but it was like few
and far between it was more of a showery
and yeah it was you know and in some
ways it was almost kind of like taxi
driver with them yeah bigger ending the
big ending at it it had like a lot more
emotional yeah stuff going on in it yes
like the relationship between him and
the and his adopted daughter yeah and
you know all that kind of stuff so you
know visit the show I was doing acting
in this yeah is acting not some acting
it's not so much just shootouts that was
a problem I think with three three was
just one big
it really wasn't that great what you
can't get boring it's a very delicate
balance like in action movies like you
don't want because people that like
action movies they want action obviously
but it can't just be wall-to-wall action
the whole time or people get bored of
that you have to have like some variety
unless it's John wick in which case well
they definitely showed us something new
in this they showed us Rambo in an urban
environment yes it was kind of out of
his out of his element he's not as good
in a urban environment yeah this isn't a
forest or a jungle or a desert because
that's what that's what Rambo specialty
was is to be you know in the wild yeah
and you know fighting gangsters in a
city is a totally different gang it's
totally different game and he's not not
that great at it
yeah watch as she wouldn't be because
that's not his specialty same situation
that's why he wanted you know to lure
them back into his own Ronnie was more
comfortable yeah he bait he ends up
luring them back to his ranch and his
ranch was already set up to be a you
know fortified offense and then it makes
it even more intense for when they show
up it's pretty cool yeah I really like
the end sequence like the last action
sequence is obvious the best one but you
know that was like that was pretty fun
the guys have played the cartel members
all did a good job they really really
came off as bad guys yeah they didn't
come off as being in apt they were all
you could tell they were all like
ex-military next police Mexican police
guys which that's usually with his court
cartel members come from and know they
had good equipment and stuff you know
it's pretty neat yeah yeah like if you
like Rambo movies I'm sure you will
probably I definitely want to see it
again I want to buy it on blu-ray yeah
and like I said I hope there's more gore
in it cuz I like that kind of I think
there's more gonna be more on that but I
think there's gonna be an unrated
release yeah more stuff on it probably
probably just like you know a good
blu-ray has the theatrical release and
then like you know the director's yes
okay there's all the extra [ __ ] that
they made us take out yeah like another
20 minutes of cool [ __ ] this should have
been a whole bunch of stuff there I feel
like they do there they probably did on
purpose now like since since DVDs and
blu-rays became a thing
yeah let's cut stuff out like on purpose
just so we have something well there was
some bad [ __ ] had happened we know it
happened but it happened off-screen yeah
I know she don't know you know
exaggerated version where it shows that
happening yeah yeah and I'd be curious
to see that because the results of it
were them yeah pretty nasty yeah oh yeah
so like I said I'm waiting for the
blu-ray if you like Rambo series and go
check it out it so it's probably be the
last one with Sylvester Stallone anyway
but like I said they might do a prequel
one of these days and I'll probably do
some expandable so I bet you [ __ ]
they'll come out with another expendable
and that's another thing you know some
said well Expendables 3 suck the
theatrical release of expendable threes
wasn't that great but I got out the
blu-ray and the the directors the
directors cut on the that comes on the
blu-ray is [ __ ] awesome
usually the director yeah it's a lot
better than the theatrical release it
depends on who the director is like the
director both self and don't bendables
three the the the director's cut blu-ray
is the best of all the Expendables I
think hmm interesting
yeah I think I watch it I didn't watch
it I don't think you saw it I saw the
first one yeah but I don't think I've
seen any of the other ones now they were
good it got better as they went as long
as you watch the correct version yeah
just burnt it yeah all right so check
out Rambo last blood in theaters now
we'll see you next time
[Music]